we asked how to sell a house if someone
had like passed away and you have to
like disclose the info if they ask you
have to disclose but you don't have to
be proactive did you run into anything
like that what my mom ended up doing she
sold the house to one of her time
traveler friends no all right I think my
mom was traumatized with the event she
was like what if like we go through an
actual escrow process and then people
ask they didn't have to reveal it and
then it's going to be re-triggering
whatever I was like sign me over to be
your power of attorney I'll sell the
house and maximize profits for you but
then I just think when a is
frazzle dazzled then she can't think
straight sometimes I feel that way she
sold it like 100 G's under Market those
Time Travelers are con artists I don't
think they're from the future I really
don't but because that lady was the
person that came over and helped my mom
conduct exorcisms like the whole week
yeah apparently there's like demons and
in there and although it's just Dad
I see him right there hey Dad see you
later all those people are con artists
yeah man taking advantage of a frazzled
dazzled
[Laughter]